What's going on guys? Mr. Zinc here. In
today's video, we're going to review the
past two days of price action using the
London 50. We're going to talk about
entries, exits, stop losses, take
profits, and all the questions that you
guys had in the comments in my last
video. Let's get right into it. Before
we get started, I want to make sure
everyone's looking at the same chart. I
use QQQ on Trading View. I do not chart
NQ or MNQ. I use QQQ with extended
trading hours on. To get extended
trading hours, go to the cog icon in the
bottom right, highlight session, and go
over to make sure there's a check mark
next to extended trading hours. To get
your London 50, it is any high or low
made between the 4 a.m. candle and the
9:15 a.m. candle. In this case, our low
was made at 5:00 a.m. and our high was
made at 8:15. Drag that out to the
right. That is your London 50 for that
trading session. Make sure that you have
the weak magnet on to make a snap to
those levels.
To get your previous days 50, it is any
high or low made between 4:00 a.m. and
8:00 p.m. In this case, we're using
Thursday's price action. Thursday was a
half day, so the close was at 4:45. The
open was still at 4 a.m. Our low was
made at 6:15 and our high was made at
11:30. Drag that out to the right. That
is our previous day's 50, otherwise
known as equilibrium by T trades. I'm
going to delete London 50 just so we can
highlight what the previous 50 does for
us. The previous day's 50
gives us our bias for the day. If price
is below the 50, we're bearish. If price
is above the 50, we're bullish. In this
case, since price opened below the 50,
and by open, I mean any candle after
9:30 or 9:15,
price opened and stayed below the 50, we
are bearish for the day. We are only
taking shorts. If price is above the 50,
we are bullish for the day. We are only
taking longs. Now, let's get that London
50 redrawn again. The low was made at
5:00 a.m. The high was made at 8:15 a.m.
Drag that out to the right. There's our
London 50 for that session. Now that we
know that we're bearish,
we're looking for short setups or we're
looking for price to reject at the
London 50. Just looking at price
right now, we would have had one, two,
three, four, five, six entry models at
the 50. And then remember, we can also
take entries below London low or above
London high. In this case, we're looking
for shorts below London low.
We had a close below London low at 10:45
and then price immediately reversed.
This would be a stopout. Simple as that.
That's going to happen with the
strategy. Nothing's going to be 100%.
But the six wins should outweigh that.
Again, we had six entries. I'm actually
going to highlight it with the rectangle
right there all the way to the 1230
entry.
Six beautiful entries. All of which
would have yielded probably about 20
points, 30 points. And I don't chart
this over on MNQ or NQ or whatever
platform I'm trading on. As you can see,
there's nothing on here but the psych
levels. 22900, 23,000, 22,800. I did
remove.
I only have psych levels every 100
points charted on M and Q. That's it. I
use QQQ to chart. I watch QQQ as I'm in
the trade. my stop loss, and this is
another common question from last video,
is a 15minute closure above or below the
level. So, let's go into replay mode and
review this entry from London low.
London low, we close below it. What I'm
looking for is a retest up to the level,
which we did get on the following
candle. As soon as that London low hits,
I'm entering short. That is, let's
review this. So that's the 1045 candle.
We're looking at the 1045 candle. There
we go. Right there. That is my entry
model. I go over to Trading View. I
enter the trade. I go back on QQQ's
chart and just watch it. My stop loss,
since I entered shorts on a close below
55263,
my stop loss is any candle that comes up
and closes back over that level. my
takeprofit really wherever you want to
put it. $50 profit, $100 profit, $30
profit, $5 profit, whatever tickles your
fancy.
Let's take a look at the next candle.
That is my stop loss right there. So,
this candle closed over the level that I
took. I took shorts at 55263. This
candle closed at 55294.
That's about a 30 cent loss on Q's. If
we correlate that over to NQ, MNQ, that
is a stop loss of about 16 points.
Not really all that bad for a risk, is
it? Now, let's review up to the next
London 50 tap.
See how long it takes for price to get
up there. There we go. London 50 got
hit.
Let me go back to that previous bar. As
soon as price hits London 50, that's
your entry for shorts. You're taking 2 M
and Q
right there. That's your entry for 2 M
andNQ.
Your stop loss is any candle that goes
over that line. Any candle that closes
over that line is your stop loss. So, if
the next candle comes up and closes like
this, you're out of the trade. Now,
let's review what happened on the next
candle. And this is one of my favorite
trades that I've taken using the
strategy. Granted, I did get lucky with
Trump talking about tariffs.
Look at the drop that we had on that
candle. Now, the wick doesn't do it
justice. The body of the candle was down
here at one point. This was 150 point
short in two minutes.
And over on Trading View, uh, excuse me,
Topep, which is what I trade on, the
candle closed at negative 55 points. But
from high to low, this was a 150 point
drop that happened in less than five
minutes.
Absolutely beautiful trade. Secure it
wherever you want to on the trade. You
don't need to let let it run to London
low, previous days low. If you see 50
bucks up here at 55316, secure it. If
you see 100, secure it. If you see 150,
200, 300, wherever you want to take
profit with the strategy, all it does
for you is gives you an entry model.
Now, if you're worried about riskreward,
if you're worried about take profits and
stop losses, this is probably not going
to be the strategy for you. If you are
more concerned with profitable trading,
securing consistent wins, and just
overall success with trading, this is
your trading strategy right here.
So again, our entry was as soon as price
went and tapped 55381, which is where
London 50 is. We have a bearish bias on
the day because the previous day's 50 is
above where price is currently trading.
We are not taking any longs unless price
gets back over that 50. Stayed below it
all day. We are bearish for the entire
day.
Shorts. Beautiful 150 point drop. 1 MQ
300 bucks. 2 MQ $600. I didn't hold it
the entire way. I probably secured it
for 150 bucks. 160 if I'm not mistaken.
And then we just go go along with our
business. What did price do? Hit the
London low. We can take a short at
London low and then as soon as price
closes either over or under that level
under it since we're in shorts we have
further confirmation to stay in those
shorts over that level we're stopped out
again for the stop loss it is any
15-minute candle that comes up and
closes over the level that you're taking
those shorts or longs.
If the candle had come up and closed
like that as such, that's probably
another 16 point stop loss. $32 per M
and Q. Not all that bad considering we
just caught 150 point drop.
Let's see how price proceeded after our
entry model hit at London low. We had a
beautiful 100 point continuation to the
downside.
Little reversal back up. Hit London low
again. So, you could have entered again
if you had secured on that 1245 candle,
hit it again. So, you could have had
another entry on that candle
and then price just continued down for
the rest of the day.
I'll exit this.
There you go. Price ended up continuing
all the way down. Closed below previous
days low, wicked all the way back up.
You're always waiting for the retest.
You're not entering on these large moves
outside of the range. You're always
looking for a retest. The reason being,
it minimizes how much you're going to
risk on the trade. It minimizes the loss
that you're going to take if the candle
does happen to close over or under the
level that you're taking. That is how we
would have traded Monday. That is how we
traded Monday, actually. And then
reviewing price to the next day. So, we
do the same exact strategy. We go ahead
and clear our London 50, draw out
previous day's high to previous day's
low, drag it to the right. That gives us
our previous day's 50 equilibrium, our
bias going into today.
Price opened over previous days 50 and
then just kind of ping ponged over under
over under over under. This is a pretty
rough trading day to say the least. Drag
our London 50 in. London 50. High was
made at 4 a.m. Low was made at 6:00 a.m.
Drag it out to the right. There's our
London 50 for today. We had one entry
model that came in at 10:30. This was
another tweet from Trump that happened
earlier this morning. One entry model at
10:30 shorts 2 MNQ followed by about a
80 point drop again in two minutes
because Trump had to open his mouth
about tariffs is what it is. And then
from there we just kind of pingponged
over under the uh previous days 50. Not
really any trading that you can do with
this and that's okay. Hey, there going
to be days that trading is rough. There
going to be days like yesterday where it
is just as perfect as it gets. You hit
the 50, you reject 150 points in two
minutes, and then you proceed lower with
previous days 50 giving you your bias.
You're not going to force trades with
this. What you're going to do is you're
going to take trades. I usually stop at
11:00
and then sometimes I look to see how
price reacts. But if you're happy with
your profits early in the day, you're
better off getting out of there, closing
the charts, locking out for the day,
waiting for the 50 or the London 50 to
form for the following day, trade that
and go on with your business. That is a
review for price action for these past
two days. Your entry model is as soon as
price hits it on the 15minute time
frame. As soon as the wick hits either
London low, London 50, London high,
previous days 50, previous days high,
previous days low. As soon as price hits
it, that's your entry. Your stop loss is
a 15minute closure over or under the
level that you're taking, depending if
you're long or short. Your takerit
wherever the hell you want it. If you're
up 20 bucks, secure it. If you're at 50
bucks, go ahead, take it. 100 bucks. Go
ahead. If you want to stretch it out,
try to make 200 bucks. Move your stop
loss to break even. Let that trade run.
I like to secure my trades for 50 to $60
profit. Sometimes I take 20 to $30
profit. This is a repetitive trading
model where you're going to have a lot
of entries with a lot of scalps. They're
successful.
Sits at about an 80% win rate. 78 to 80%
in that range. Some days are good, some
days are bad. It all evens out in the
long run. I hope you enjoyed that
review. Any other questions that you
guys have, drop them in the comments.
I'll try to answer them on every video
that I have from here on out.
I'll try to get a response out, reply to
those questions. Drop a like, subscribe
to the channel, let me know what you
want to see for the next video. See you
guys later. Peace out.